♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO A SPECIAL EDITION OF
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IN ONE OF HER FIRST OFFICIAL
ACTS AS VICE PRESIDENT BACK IN
FEBRUARY, KAMALA HARRIS DECIDED
TO DECLARE WHAT SHE CALLED A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
AND RIGHT AWAY THAT SEEMS
STRANGE.
NORMALLY, IT'S THE PRESIDENT'S
JOB TO DECLARE NATIONAL
EMERGENCIES.
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S JOB IS TO
OVERSEE VICE.
JUST KIDDING.
WE'RE NOT SURE WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S JOB IS BUT IT
IS CERTAINLY NOT THAT.
BUT, HERE IS DID IT ANYWAY IN
THE PAGES OF JEFF BEZOS'
PERSONAL NEWSPAPER,
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
THIS NEW NATIONAL EMERGENCY,
KAMALA HARRIS INFORMED US IS
"THE MASS EXODUS OF WOMEN FROM
THE WORKPLACE."
APPARENTLY THERE IS STILL SOME
WOMEN IN AMERICA WHO SECRETLY
PREFER TO RAISE THEIR OWN
CHILDREN RATHER THAN TOIL AWAY
FOR WORKER BEES FOR SOME
SOULLESS, PUBLICLY TRADED
CORPORATION.
WALL STREET IS UPSET ABOUT THAT
OF COURSE THE KAMALA HARRIS
SOUNDED THE ALARM.
OUR FEMALE WORKFORCE EMERGENCY,
SHE WROTE, DEMANDS A NATIONAL
SOLUTION.
FIVE MONTHS LATER WE ARE SAD TO
TELL YOU THAT THAT CRISIS
IS STILL ONGOING.
THERE ARE WOMEN, EVEN NOW, WHO
HAVE CHOSEN TO SKIP THE HR
DEPARTMENT'S LATEST DOOM:
WORKPLACE DIVERSITY INITIATIVES
AND ARE INSTEAD READING THE
CHILDREN A BEDTIME STORY.
AND THAT IS A TRAGEDY.
AND KAMALA HARRIS HASN'T DONE A
LOT TO HELP.
IN FACT THERE IS NOW A MASS
EXODUS OF WOMEN FROM HER
OFFICE PEER THE TOXIC
MASCULINITY IS COMING FROM
INSIDE THE HOUSE.
THIS WEEK, POLITICO REPORTED,
SEVERAL TOP FEMALE HARRIS
STAFFERS HAVE QUIT AFTER THEY
SAY THEY WERE ABUSED.
"IT IS NOT A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
AND PEOPLE OFTEN FEEL
MISTREATED" SAID ONE.
IT'S NOT A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
FEEL SUPPORTED BUT A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE FEEL THEY ARE TREATED
LIKE CRAP.
HER TEAM WAS FEELING POROUS
LINES OF COMMUNICATION AND
DIMINISHED TRUST BETWEEN 80 AND
SENIOR OFFICIALS AND THE ARTICLE
GOES ON TO MAKE THE EXCUSES FOR
ALL OF THIS.
"BLACK WOMEN ARE SUBJECTED TO
STANDARDS THAT MEN OFTEN DON'T
HAVE TO CLEAR."
RIGHT.
IN OTHER WORDS, BECAUSE
KAMALA HARRIS' FATHER CAME FROM
THE CARIBBEAN, IT'S OKAY THAT
SHE IS A MONSTER TO WORK FOR.
GOT IT, HOPE THAT IS COMFORTING
TO THE WOMEN WHOSE LIVES SHE'S
WRECKED.
WE DO SEE A PATTERN HERE,
THOUGH.
FIRST, KAMALA HARRIS TAKES
CHARGE OF A PROBLEM SHE DOESN'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND, AND LET'S
HELP WOMEN IN THE WORKFORCE, SHE
SAYS, THEN PROCEEDS TO DRIVE
WOMEN OUT OF HER OWN OFFICE.
LET'S FIX THE BORDER CRISIS, SHE
SAYS, AS THE WAVE OF ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS BECOMES A TSUNAMI.
TAKE THIS VACCINE, SHE TELLS
YOU, IT WORKS PERFECTLY.
THEN SHE TURNS TO KISS HER
VACCINATED HUSBAND WHILE WEARING
A SURGICAL MASK.
ON ONE LEVEL IT IS HILARIOUS TO
WATCH ALL THIS.
THEY TELL US KAMALA HARRIS IS
VERY IMPRESSIVE, BUT LOOK AT
HER, SHE IS A JOKE, SHE CAN
BARELY GET THROUGH THE DAY, SHE
HAS NO IDEA WHAT SHE'S DOING
PEER BUT YOU CAN'T SAY THAT OUT
LOUD.
SHUT UP AND ACCEPT KAMALA'S
DOMINION OVER YOU PAIR THAT IS
THE NEW RULE.
POINT OUT THAT SHE IS A
POWER-HUNGRY BUFFOON POSING AS A
COMPETENT ADULT THEY WILL
INSTANTLY DENOUNCE HE WAS A
RACIST.
THEY DO THAT BECAUSE IT WORKS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE PARTICULARLY AT
THE NEWS MEDIA STILL FIND THE
IDEA OF BEING CALLED A RACIST OF
THE SCARIEST THING THEY CAN
IMAGINE, SCARIER THAN DYING, SO
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING TO AVOID
THAT, INCLUDING IGNORING
KAMALA HARRIS' OBVIOUS
MEDIOCRITY.
AS A RESULT, THEY BARELY COVER
HER AND WE ARE GOING TO FILL THE
NEXT HOUR FILLING THAT GAP.
KAMALA HARRIS MAY BE ONE OF THE
LEAST IMPRESSIVE PEOPLE ON
PUBLIC LIFE BUT IN SOME DAYS IT
FEELS LIKE SHE'S RUNNING OUR
COUNTRY ANYWAY.
LAST MONTH THE PRESIDENT OF
MEXICO OF ALL PEOPLE MADE THAT
POINT.
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE]
>> Tucker: AND NOT THE ONLY
ONE, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CALLS HER
PRESIDENT.
AND IN THIS COUNTRY, VOTERS HAVE
COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT IN
FACT, SHE IS.
THE DASH GROUP IS ONE OF THE
ONLY POLLING COMPANIES WORTH
PAYING ATTENTION TO AT THIS
POINT.
THEY GOT THE LAST ELECTION
ALMOST EXACTLY RIGHT WHEN FEW
OTHER FIRMS WERE EVEN CLOSE.
TONIGHT WE HAVE EXCLUSIVE NEW
POLLING THAT SHOWS WHO AMERICANS
BELIEVE IS ACTUALLY RUNNING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS SAY
JOE BIDEN WASN'T IN CHARGE AND
IT WASN'T SIMPLY REPUBLICANS WHO
THOUGHT THAT.
A THIRD OF DEMOCRATS SAY BIDEN
IS NOT ACTUALLY IN CHARGE.
10% WEREN'T SURE WHICH IS PRETTY
MUCH THE SAME THING.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THEY HAVE
EVER BEEN NUMBERS LIKE THAT IN
HISTORY ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
WHAT DID THEY TELL US?
THEY TELL US THAT THE MEDIA
STORY LINE, THE ONE YOU HERE
EVERY DAY, JOE BIDEN IS FINE,
HE'S JUST GOT A REALLY BAD
STUTTER, RELAX!
ISN'T ACTUALLY FOOLING ANYONE
BUT NOT FOR THE LACK OF TRYING.
OUTSIDE OF THIS CHANNEL NO ONE
ON TELEVISION IS ALLOWED TO SAY
WHAT SEEMS OBVIOUS WHICH IS THAT
BIDEN CAN'T REALLY DO HIS JOB.
THAT IS FORBIDDEN PRECISELY
BECAUSE IT IS TRUE.
BUT JOE ROGAN DOESN'T WORK ON
TELEVISION, HE HOSTS THE PODCAST
SO HE CAN SAY ANYTHING HE WANTS,
AND RECENTLY, HE DID.
>> THEY ARE UNHINGED IN A LOT OF
WAYS AND WE ARE NOT ANCHORED
DOWN BY A REAL LEADER.
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A REAL
LEADER IN THIS COUNTRY ANYMORE.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU CAN SAY JOE BIDEN IS THE
PRESIDENT AND HE IS OUR LEADER
AND HE WOULD BE CORRECT ON
PAPER, BUT EVERYBODY KNOWS HE IS
OUT OF HIS MIND.
HE'S BARELY HANGING IN THERE.
>> Tucker: WELL, EXACTLY.
WE KNOWS A LOT ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S
DECLINE ON THAT SHOW PARTLY
BECAUSE IT IS DEPRESSING AND
PARTLY BECAUSE OUR DEFAULT
POSITION IS TO ALWAYS RESPECT
OLD PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
GET A LITTLE SOFT, AS WE ALL
KNOW WHEN WE LIVE LONG ENOUGH SO
IT'S BAD KARMA TO MOCK THEM FOR
A PEER BUT IN BIDEN'S CASE, IT'S
DEMONSTRABLY TRUE AND EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT INCLUDING HIS FAMILY.
WHO IS REALLY IN CHARGE OF
JOE BIDEN ISN'T AN INCREASINGLY
IT SEEMS LIKE KAMALA HARRIS IS
RUNNING THING.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN DEMOCRACY,
THIS IS A PROBLEM.
NO LARGE GROUP OF PEOPLE HAS
EVER SIGNALED THE DESIRE TO PUT
KAMALA HARRIS IN CONTROL OF THE
COUNTRY FOR JUST THE OPPOSITE.
AT THE HEIGHT OF LESS DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY SEASON, MOST OF HER OWN
CONSTITUENTS TOLD POLLSTERS THEY
WANTED HER TO DROP OUT OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
ONLY 7% OF DEMOCRATS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THOUGHT
THEIR SENATOR, KAMALA HARRIS,
SHOULD BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
TO THE PEOPLE WHO NO HER BEST
HAVE THE LEAST RESPECT FOR HER.
BUT SHE GOT THE JOB ANYWAY
ENTIRELY BY DEFAULT.
HERE'S THE PRESIDENT DEMOCRATS
THOUGHT THEY WERE VOTING FOR.
>> EMPLOYEES CAN'T FIND WORKERS.
I SAID, YEAH, PAY THEM MORE.
THIS IS IN EMPLOYEES' A
BARGAINING CHIP NOW.
WHAT IS HAPPENING?
[WHISPERING]
>> THEY ARE GETTING CHECKS IN
THE MAIL, CONSEQUENTIAL THIS
WEEK FOR JOB CARE.
[WHISPERING]
>> WHY WOULD I NOT BEFORE IT
QUESTION CUSTOMER >> Tucker:
WHAT WAS THAT?
YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IT IS, BUT
THEY ARE PRETENDING LIKE YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
IF YOU LOOK AT SOME WIDE SHOTS
WILL YOU SEE THE MUTUAL
PROPAGANDISTS FROM CBS AND
OTHERS SMILING, PRETENDING IT IS
TOTALLY NORMAL BUT IT IS NOT
NORMAL AT ALL.
THAT IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS IS A HUGE AND DRAMATIC
CHANGE TO OUR SYSTEM OF
GOVERNMENT